Rachel Dolezal gets herself in trouble
again plus we discuss president Trump's
pullout from the North Korean summit and
we talk to Memorial Day this is the Ben
Shapiro show well it is a day on which
we celebrate the Valor of our soldiers
of our of our service people all over
the world
and I want to start the show today by
talking a little bit about some things
you may not know about Memorial Day now
this is from history calm so this
information is I think really useful and
relevant and pretty cool actually
because most folks don't really know all
that much about Memorial Day I will
admit that I didn't until fairly
recently some of the stuff is really
neat so did you know that
Memorial Day one of the first Memorial
did one of the first commemorations of a
Memorial Day was organized by recently
freed slaves so according to history
calm as the Civil War neared its end
thousands of Union soldiers held as
prisoners of war were herded into a
series of hastily assembled camps in
Charleston South Carolina conditions at
one camp a former racetrack near the
city Citadel were so bad that more than
two hundred and fifty prisoners died
from disease or exposure and were buried
in a mass grave behind the tracks at
grandstand actually this is one of the
great untold stories of the Civil War is
the differing prison camps that were
held by the north and the south there's
a very good book about one of those
prison camps that was those in the South
that ended up with thousands of people
dying in just horrific conditions people
being held outdoors without tents I mean
just horrendous stuff three weeks after
the Confederate surrender an unusual
procession entered the former camp on
May 1st 1865 more than 1,000 recently
freed slaves accompanied by regiments of
US Colored Troops including the
Massachusetts 54th infantry and a
handful of white Charlestonians gather
in the camp to consecrate a new proper
burial site for the Union dead the group
sang hymns it gave readings and
distributed flowers around the cemetery
which they dedicated to the martyrs of
the racecourse the racecourse of course
being the place where they had held this
awful awful prison kemon brutality the
Civil War really cannot be overstated
and this is why it's so frustrating when
people overlook the legacy of the
literally hundreds of thousands of
American troops who gave their lives to
end the evil of slavery within American
borders it's an amazing thing and to
overlook that and to pretend that
Americans made no sacrifices on this
score is just to be historically
ignorant now doesn't mean all the
problems got solved obviously 1865 but
America so
elders have spent their lives in their
blood they've spent their days their
years you know upholding America's first
freedoms and those freedoms are deeply
important to the cause of freedom in the
world obviously obviously thanks
soldiers who are stationed around the
globe right now I'm sure listening to
the sound of my voice we have lots of
members of the military who listen to
the show thank God for them and thank
them for listening
holidays founder was a guy named General
John Logan he was commander in chief of
the Union veterans group known as the
Grand Army of the Republic and he issued
a decree on that May 30th 1868 should
become a nationwide day of commemoration
for more than six hundred twenty
thousand soldiers killed in the recently
ended civil war on declaration day as
Logan dubbed it Americans should lay
flowers and decorate the graves of the
war dead whose bodies now lie in almost
every city village and Hamlet churchyard
in the land according to legend Logan
chose May 30th because it was a rare day
that didn't fall on the anniversary of a
Civil War battle because there were so
many Civil War battles some historians
think that the date was selected to
ensure that flowers across the country
would be in full full bloom according to
history calm after the war Logan who
served as US congressman before
resigning to join the army returned to
politics and he eventually served in
both the House and the Senate he ran for
vice-president in 1884 unsuccessfully
and his body was laid in states at the
US Capitol he was just one of 33 people
to have received the honor
apparently he adapted the idea from
earlier events in the south because in
April 1886 the ladies Memorial
Association of Columbus Georgia resolved
to commemorate the fallen once a year
which was the decision that seemed to
have influenced Logan to follow suit
according to his own wife but
commemorations were rarely held on one
standard day they were sort of held on a
variety of days it didn't actually
become a federal holiday until 1971
because declarations day is what it was
called the first year more than 27
States held some sort of ceremony with
more than 5,000 people in attendance at
a ceremony and Arlington National
Cemetery by 1890 every former State of
the Union had adopted it as an official
holiday but for more than 50 years the
holiday was used to commemorate those
killed just in the Civil War not in any
other American conflict and then after
World War one it was it expanded out to
include those killed in all wars
Memorial Day obviously as opposed to
Veterans Day which is about everybody
who served Memorial Day specifically
about people who gave their lives in
order to preserve the freedom of the
Union so I think I find this stuff
fascinating according to
street comm although the term Memorial
Tate was used beginning in the 1880s the
holiday was officially known as
declaration it for more than a century
and then it was changed by federal law
as you mentioned well four years later
the uniform Monday holiday Act of 1968
finally went into effect in a move
Memorial Day from its observance on May
30th regardless of the day of the week
to set it for the last Monday in May a
lot of veterans groups were concerned
that a lot of people saw it as a long
weekend as opposed to a day to pay
tribute to our fallen soldiers for more
than 20 years their cause was championed
by Senator Daniel Inouye who recently
died in 2012 he had reintroduce
legislation to set it any day in the
middle of the week you wouldn't just
been on a Monday it wouldn't been
another a long weekend it would have
been a time when we all stand and pay
tribute to fallen soldiers honestly I'm
in favor of that I think that we should
move it to whatever day May 30th is we
should move it back to its original date
said it doesn't just become another day
that you have off and you take it off
for a long weekend yes we can enjoy
Memorial Day but obviously we should
have half our brain more than half our
brain I'm the reason that we are
spending that day barbecuing as opposed
to working and we should all you know
try to do something for a soldier that
day or a soldier's family that's a in
Israel they do this right in Israel they
actually stop all traffic in the country
at a particular time on the fallen
soldiers day in Israel and they place
they play air-raid sirens all across the
country people literally stop their cars
on the freeway get out of their cars and
stand there until the air-raid siren is
over we should have something like that
in the United States as well despite the
increasing celebration of the holidays
of summer right of passage there are
still some formal rituals on the books
the American flag is supposed to be hung
at half-staff until noon on Memorial Day
and then raised to the top of the staff
and since 2000 when the US Congress
passed legislation all Americans are
encouraged to pause for national moments
of remembrance at 3 p.m. local time
so that should actually be formalized we
should have whatever noise it is sirens
whatever it is to ensure that at 3:00
p.m. everybody stops what they are doing
the federal government has also used the
holiday to honor non veterans the
Lincoln Memorial was dedicated on
Memorial Day in 1922 the Indy 500 has
become its own Memorial Day tradition
obviously the reason that I think it's
important to remember all of this is
because we live in a country when there
are very few unifying symbols there very
few unifying things that bring us
together we fight about everything with
each other all the time we seem to
really
like each other in a lot of ways but
this is one where we should all come
together and it's unfortunate that
during the 1960's a lot of the
patriotism surrounding our fallen
soldiers was lost during the 1960's
soldiers who are coming back from
Vietnam were treated really terribly
even now there's this weird idea on the
left that soldiers are either heroes or
victims and that if a soldier goes off
to serve in a foreign land and dies
heroically that soldier was somehow a
victim of the government that sends him
over there in the first place we haven't
violence here army now I've always found
this idea really insulting these
soldiers are making a sacrifice and the
sacrifice that they are making they're
doing with full knowledge of what it is
they are getting into that's what makes
the sacrifice worth worth making that's
what makes the sacrifice so incredible
and making more of a sacrifice than I
have and making more of a sacrifice than
virtually anyone in my generation has
mean the number of people in my
generation joining the military is still
extraordinarily low they're doing
something I did not do they're doing
something I did not have the bravery and
the courage and the decency to do that's
an amazing thing and to rob them of the
volition of that choice by suggesting
that when American soldiers die they die
in vain or that when American soldiers
die they are victims of the evil
American corporate hierarchy and the
evil American government these are
independent minded people who are making
the most altruistic decision they can
which is to take their own lives and put
them on the line for us
to rob them of that volition is to rob
them of what makes their lives
meaningful in the first place it's also
a great time to remember that for all of
the leftists talk about how America has
been a terrible force in the world how
America is responsible for slavery and
imperialism and colonialism wherever
American troops have set their boots the
world is a better place wherever
American troops have kept their boots
the world is certainly a better place
hey if you don't believe me just look at
a rock and there's a lot of talk about
how Iraq is a worse place because we
intervene no Iraq is a worse place
because we pulled out when American
troops entered Iraq Ameri Iraq was run
by the Saddam Hussein dictatorship where
women were being forcibly imprisoned and
raped and tortured by Saddam Hussein's
sons
it was a hellhole he was gassing his own
people the Kurds and when we went in we
broke a lot of stuff and a lot of people
died and that is awful but there is no
question that the place got a lot worse
when America pulled out hey we're
American troops set their boots things
get better which is why still the vast
majority of oppressed people
planet Earth if they could would look to
the arrival of the American flag in
their land as a as an opportunity to cut
back repression and to fight repression
as opposed to imperialism colonialism
look at these evil Americans and all the
rest again the reality is that America
has freed Europe but not once but twice
America has freed about has freed the
world of the Soviet Menace okay that is
due to the sacrifice of American
soldiers our history is long and
glorious with regards to our military
interventions and that is certainly true
including wars like Vietnam which was
not a war fought for American imperial
interests it was a war fought to
preserve South Vietnam independence
there's a war fought to preserve the
democracy of Vietnam and to move toward
a better democracy in Vietnam and saved
them from the repression and evil of the
Vietcong administration which resulted
in the deaths of hundreds of thousands
of people including in Cambodia just
across the border domino theory was
correct
Cambodia did fall and a million people
were killed by Pol Pot when America
precipitously pulls out things get bad
when America stays Germany becomes nice
Germany and nobody thinks of Germany as
a threatening country anymore why
because America over ran Germany along
with her allies and then proceeded to
turn Germany into a thriving Western
democracy and the same thing is true in
Japan which was a complete imperialist
dictatorship and then America came in
with our troops and we occupied the
place and there are still troops in
Japan South Korea is only free because
of American troops because of American
material and American men and women
willing to sacrifice their lives in
order to make South Koreans free the
reason they're not all living under the
Gulag conditions of kim jeong-hoon is
because of the strength and power of
America's military might this is why
whenever there's an attempt by folks on
the left to cut back America's military
the case being that a strong virile
military scares people it makes the
world a scarier worse place the answer
is every time we do that that is
immediately followed by some sort of
terrorist attack or brutal attack on
Americans and then we have to build up
our military again Bill Clinton spent
years cutting back the American military
and then there was the attack of 9/11
and then we had to rebuild the American
military the threat either is stopped
there or it comes here the same was true
in Pearl Harbor by 1941 by the time of
America's entry into World War two and
Pearl Harbor the American military the
standing American
military was smaller than the standing
military of the Philippines Americ had
the 16th largest military on planet
earth in 1941 and we ramped back up if
America had been a lot more muscular on
the world stage and had attempted to
prevent the imperialism of the Japanese
and the imperialism of the of the
Germans earlier than that working with
our allies a lot of lives had been saved
a lot of lives would have been saved and
there's this this weird idea that's
risen in both isolationist circles and
leftist circles it is sort of where a
lot of Ron Paul foreign policy fans runs
directly into the arms of Bernie Sanders
foreign policy fans then America's
presence on the world stage is
unnecessary that if we draw nothing bad
happens that it's not in America's
interest to be quote unquote global
policeman we don't have to be global
policeman nobody suggesting that America
has to be the world police and save
everybody from themselves but we do have
to assess what is in America's interests
where do the gravest threats lie and
then we have to be active on those
threats because just like with policing
if you are not proactively policing a
particular area it goes to hell in a
handbasket and soon those areas spread
broken windows theory doesn't just apply
to domestic crime it also applies to
foreign policy which again does not mean
that America has to compromise our own
safety and security and the use of our
military force for every small
humanitarian mission it doesn't mean
that when we can we should and it also
means that morality has a heavy part to
play in America's foreign policy it has
always had a heavy part to play in
America's foreign policy there's this
realist idea out there that morality
doesn't play any role in in what we do
on foreign policy and obviously the
American people do not disagree do not
agree with that the American people
believe that there is still room for
virtue in American foreign policy which
is why we have this really divided mind
about foreign policy that I think we
need to figure out because otherwise
we're putting our own soldiers in
unwinnable situations the divided mind
goes like this something terrible
happens on a farm front there's a
slaughter in in Syria there's a
slaughter in Sudan there's a saw a
slaughter in Somalia and the American
people say see it on TV they say that
looks awful we need to do something
about that that looks terrible
and then whatever American
administration is in power Republicans
Democrats doesn't matter they say okay
we'll respond to that by doing something
and then within five weeks the American
people say we really shouldn't be in
there you know
there's no reason for us to be in there
in the first place foreign policy should
be conducted along the lines of a
long-range attempt to figure out exactly
what is in America's interest if we can
do that then we can ensure that we are
using our military in the best possible
way and that our military members signed
up for the right gig but on this
Memorial Day it's time to stop and say
thank you to all of the members of the
military who laid down their lives so
that we could spend today having fun and
then I could do my podcast and then I
could spend time with my family and that
you could do whatever it is that you're
doing today there's a free and wonderful
country because of the power and might
of the American military the greatest
force for freedom in the history of
mankind okay meanwhile speaking of
foreign policy there is there's a lot of
hubbub over the weekend and and today
about President Trump and North Korea
obviously last week President Trump
pulled out of the summit with North
Korea and now they're rumors that the
summit is going to be back on with North
Korea this is a negotiation tactic by
President Trump I don't think that
President Trump should be giving us
constant updates on whether there's
going to be a summit with North Korea I
think the reason for that is that if he
continues to give us these constant
updates about what's going on with North
Korea it makes it seem as though he is
desperate to have this meeting with
North Korea America should never be
desperate to have a meeting with anybody
we're the most powerful country on the
face of the earth and in the history of
the world there's no reason we should be
desperate to meet with a tin-pot
dictator it is his job to come to us
with something to give up so that we can
reinstate him in the community of
nations now President Trump is saying
that North Korea blew it on the summit
and you know basically this is right
based on the recent statement of North
Korea I've decided to terminate the plan
summit in Singapore on June 12th well
many things can happen and a great
opportunity lies ahead potentially I
believe that this is a tremendous
setback for North Korea and indeed a
setback for the world okay well this is
a negotiation tactic by President Trump
Democrats however are celebrating the
fact that the summit fell apart so it's
hilarious the Democrats who were saying
he never should have held this um in the
first place are celebrating the fact
that it fell apart now basically
whatever Trump does they proceeded to do
the opposite so Nancy Pelosi comes out
she says Kim jong-eun must be having a
giggle fit over the canceled summit well
it really is having a giggle felt like
why
you can go back to his crappy his
crapoly run country with its exploded
nuclear mountain and continue to
impoverishes on people like where's the
giggle fed I'm not really seeing the
evidence of this I think it's a good
thing for Kim Jung hoon here you had a
thug a person who killed all his own
family members
a person who has runs a police state
being legitimized by the President of
the United States they were on a par
with each other he got the global
recognition and regard he's the big
winner and when he got this letter from
the president saying okay never mind he
must be having a giggle fit right there
there's no evidence whatsoever Kim
jong-un is happy about any of this but
that's not gonna stop Democrats from
claiming that Kim Jong moon is happy
about all of this because their
opposition to Trump is much stronger
than their opposition to Kim jong-un you
can figure that with a nuclear-armed
evil dictator we might all be able to
get at least a little bit on the same
page as far as who's the bad guy in the
narrative but apparently Democrats are
unable to do that speaking of which
there's a lot of talk before the
election about President Trump and
Russia Russia collusion and president
Trump is going to be giving up power
over American foreign policy to the
Russia ins and all of the rest of this
well that obviously has not happened
president Trump has been quite harsh
with the Russians he's imposed a lot of
sanctions that the Obama administration
did not his arm the Ukrainians the
Ukrainian government was thanking
president Trump just last week for
arming them properly or more properly
well now it has come up that Malaysia
Airlines flight 17 which was shot down
over eastern Ukraine in 2014 that was
shot down indeed by a group connected
with Russia at the time Russia denied
any involvement in the crash that killed
all those aboard a news conference in
the Netherlands last week Wilbert
policin of the Dutch National Police
announced that after investigators had
scrutinized the images it was determined
that the missile originated from
Russia's 53rd anti-aircraft missile
brigade from the city of Kursk in
western Russia in western Russia the
missile was part of the Russian Armed
Forces friend Westerbeck II whose chief
prosecutor of the National Prosecutor's
Office of the Netherlands according to
media I also noted that at the time the
plane went down the area was controlled
by Russian separatists he said that this
raises questions such as to whether the
brigade was actively involved in downing
MH 17 it's an important question which
the joint investigation team are still
investigating Russia continues to deny
any involvement of course the Russian
Defense Ministry announced
both in his first hours after the
tragedy and further officially denied
the insinuations of the Ukrainian side
about the alleged involvement of Russian
servicemen to the catastrophe that
happened in the skies of Ukraine and
brought the relevant evidence to the
Dutch investigation team Vladimir Putin
is in evil human being his regime is
evil and his conducted acts of evil that
was 300 dead for no reason other than
Russian militarism president Trump has
stood up to the Russia this is this is
the part of the quid pro quo I don't
understand if the idea was the Russians
were going to elect Trump said they
would get sub backed something from
Trump I'm waiting for the thing that
they are getting back from Trump I'm
just not seeing the evidence of this I
just don't see the evidence of this and
although all the Democrats are
complaining about Russian interference
in the election I'd like to see them be
half as upset when Russia actually kills
journalists or in Russia invade
sovereign countries as they did to
Crimea and President Obama did nothing
or when they took controlled Syria and
President Obama facilitated all of that
in other words it's Democrats playing
politics with foreign policy and I just
I find it abhorrent that they are so
attached to the idea that Republicans
are the bad guys they can't even get
together on some pretty obvious matters
here okay meanwhile President Obama made
an amazing statement at the end of last
week and this statement is worthy of
discussion so the statement is that he
did not have scandals as president hey
the coverage of scandals by the media is
completely disproportionate between
Republicans and Democrats this is the
real issue here but so President Obama
according to Newsweek took a light swing
at his successor during a tech
conference in Las Vegas on Wednesday he
said his eight years in office were
scandal-free he says I didn't have
scandals which seems like it shouldn't
be something you brag about and he said
actually if you look at the history of
the modern presidency coming out of the
modern presidency without anybody going
to jail is really good it's a big deal
he said no one in my white house never
got in trouble for screwing up as long
as there wasn't malicious intent behind
it okay
this of course is the point right you
see him allied the point right there at
the very end where he says no one got in
trouble because there was no malicious
intent does that ring a few bells
malicious intent that was the excuse
used by James Comey in the FBI not to
prosecute Hillary Clinton for
maliciously setting up a private server
to hide her emails in putting 33,000
emails on there and then destroying all
of them hey so that was not malicious
intent
according to James Comey and so it obama
says is maybe we had scandals I mean
maybe we did
scandalous but we never meant to do
scandalous stuff absolute hogwash
absolute nonsense his administration was
certainly not scandal-free Benghazi it
was a major scandal despite what
Democrats would say hey this was a
scandal in which the State Department
repeatedly refused requests by
ambassador Chris Stevens for additional
security in Benghazi no no troops were
forthcoming in the middle of a 17 hour
attack in the middle of the a huge
attack in in Benghazi our 13 hour attack
in Benghazi and nothing came and then
there was a cover-up by the Obama
administration claiming had nothing to
do with lack of security or Libyan
policy in the first place instead what
it really had to do with was if it was a
video made by some anonymous YouTube
guide nobody had ever heard of Schnauzer
scandal there's fast and furious in
which the Obama administration greenlit
the movement of killing weapons as they
would say down to Mexican drug cartels
which were then used in the murder of US
border Agent Brian Terry you remember
that the Obama administration was
involved in the IRS scandal in which
Obama's IRS suspiciously started
targeting only conservative 501c3 groups
they claimed no no no we never would do
that of course that's exactly what
happened the Obama administration was
repeatedly involved in deep levels of
corruption no-one was prosecuted because
the DOJ was run by Barack Obama's
wingman Eric Holder but here's the real
point Barack Obama thinks that he was
never involved in a scandal because he
was not according to the media according
to the media he was never involved in a
scandal and this has been a repeat point
of contention for folks on write a lot
of people on the Left don't understand
why so many folks on the right are so
upset all the time about the media why
are we so upset about the media aren't
the media just trying to tell the truth
don't the media have a job to do here's
the problem whenever a Democrat gets
involved in a scandal the coverage is
less blanket shall we say then the
coverage of Republican when a Republican
is involved in a similar scandal right
you still like do you even remember the
name of that New York Attorney General
who had to resign because he was calling
girlfriends his slaves and then sexually
abusing them do you remember that guy
allegedly he allegedly sexually abusing
them remember that guy his name was Eric
Schneiderman they lasted for five hours
right mean that's that sucker was over
immediately and that was over as fast as
it began but think of Republicans for
whom this has happened the David Vitter
scandal went on for a long time that was
a Consent
affair with a call girl and that went on
for a lot longer the Donald Trump
scandals obviously have continued for a
lot longer now you may say well what
about Republicans who resigned did the
scandals continue for them the answer is
yes the scandals does continue for
Republicans who resigned from office Bob
Packwood
obviously is still synonymous with
scandal so I mean you can go all the way
back with this can the media have
guarded Democrats with their with their
pens for years hey here's the latest
story about this okay and it's not
played by the like this.for it's not
played this way before the New York Post
by the New York Post but this is
obviously the hidden story here in May
1961 an elderly woman in Paris heard a
knock at the door of her 6-story walk-up
apartment it was the only powerful man
only it was only the most powerful man
in the world the President of the United
States was going door to door hoping to
find the call girl he had discreetly
arranged to meet John F Kennedy it
turned out used a fake excuse about a
doctor's visit to attend a long arranged
dalliance well in Paris for a crucial
summit only and wind up in the wrong
building knocking on the doors of random
Parisians who were left with the
surprise of their lives
the tale of this ill-advised but
ultimately successful liaison is
recorded in madam cloud her secret world
of pleasure privilege and power by
William studien madam cloud born
Fernan grew day in 1923 and engineer
France was one of the world's most
successful Madam's starting in 1957 she
ran an exclusive high-class prostitution
ring that offered a very specific type
of woman tall supermodel gorgeous classy
and upscale or at least trained to
appear so - the world's richest and most
powerful men the only woman who worked
for her were known as Claude girls which
became a well-known in powerful brand
she scouted them carefully paid for
plastic surgery if needed and ultimately
hoped to marry them off to aristocracy a
day with a cloud girl was one of those
pinnacle Paris experiences right Stadium
like staying at the Ritz or a dinner at
Maxine's
whoring a Lanvin suit an apotheosis of
luxury the French can do better than any
other nationality according to Stadium
Madame's clouds client lists included
the world's most successful men Kennedy
Frank Sinatra Pablo Picasso Marc Chagall
Sammy Davis jr. former vice president
Nelson Rockefeller three generations of
Geddes Marlon Brando Groucho Marx few
rich famous and male in the 20th century
Chancellor madam cloud knew what you
liked in bed and provided exactly that
for Kennedy his desired liaison required
almost as much detailed preparation as
an actual political summit after the Bay
of Pigs fiasco in April 1961 Kennedy
thought a meeting in your
with French and Soviet leaders Charles
de Gaulle and Nikita Khrushchev
respectively could serve as a reset for
his presidency he decided that he and
first lady Jackie Kennedy would embark
on their first official European tour
this would be the trip where Jackie so
entranced the French Kennedy famously
introduced himself as the man who
accompanied Jacqueline Jacqueline
Kennedy to Paris but while Jackie was
thrilled to the prospect of meeting
novelist and newly appointed French
Culture Minister Andre malroux one of
her literary idols her husband looked to
fulfill a different sort of fantasy if
JFK had a type it was a wholesome snooty
proper preppy girl who's flaunted
untouchability he could violate girls
lay shackle in Bouvier Wright's stadium
who notes that Kennedy learned about
Madame Claude from Sinatra here was a
Madame who specialized in exactly what
JFK was after the liaison was apparently
arranged between madame clown and pierre
salinger
Kennedy's press secretary when Salinger
first proposed the arrangement cloud
turned him down fearing the many things
that could go wrong if the president's
visit to a prostitute went haywire but
Salinger convinced cloud that any
problems could work in her favor a
scandal would make her a legends of the
sex comfortable French and that a
successful dalliance would bring her to
the attention of the world's most
powerful men so Salinger who's again
this is JFK's private secretary exhorted
the madam quote rise to the occasion
do it for your career do it for your
country he rift paraphrasing JFK's
inaugural address think big
weighing risks and rewards like the
shrewd banker she might have otherwise
been cloud decided to go for it
so Kennedy wanted to hook up with a
French actress who looked like Jackie
Kennedy and apparently that didn't work
so instead he decided to go to a
now here's the real question it's not
that was 1961 it is now 2018 it took 57
years for this hit the press 57 years
for the test the press do you really
think the press weren't there in Paris
at a meeting with Charles de Gaulle and
Nikita Khrushchev do you think the press
really weren't around for any of this do
you think the press really didn't know
about it
the press knew about everything they
know about everything that was going on
with JFK
hey the plan was apparently for the four
malroux this this French culture
minister to play tour guide to the first
lady while the president visited French
historical sites but then Kennedy begged
off claiming a flare-up of his bad back
and saying he needed to visit a French
pain specialist but instead he had
brought his dr. feelgood max Jacobson
for cover and they headed off to find
his mystery lover only to wind up at the
wrong apartment so again is it possible
the press didn't know about this
unlikely and cuz JFK did this kind of
crap all the time the Kennedys did this
kind of stuff all the time the Camelot
imaged the press plastered across the
front pages it was all a lie now you
might say that these lies were done for
the sake of the American public they did
this with Hollywood stars at the time
they did it with all presidents at the
time all politicians at the time but
that is clearly not true because even
today the press treat JFK with this sort
of glamour and sophistication JFK was a
significantly worse person in many ways
than Bill Clinton okay and Bill Clinton
isn't nobody's idea of a saint and yet
JFK is treated as this wonderful guy
right nobody talks about shipping
Kennedy off the Kennedy Center nobody
talks about taking that chisel and just
chipping that right off the Kennedy
Center talking about removing Woodrow
Wilson's name from the Woodrow Wilson
School over Princeton but they will
never talk about removing JFK's name
even though Kennedy was indeed the worst
kind of sexual scumbag none that matters
right that's totally fine because
Kennedy was Kennedy and then you wonder
why people on the right don't respect
the press you want to write people on
the right have no respect for how it is
that the the press Khoa bout their
business it's because of stuff like this
now meanwhile and apparently the least
shocking news of the day Rachel Dolezal
you remember her she's the white lady
who said that she was black and then she
ended up working for the Spokane chapter
of the n-double a-c-p and then it turned
out that she was actually just a white
girl from Kansas well now it turns out
that according to KHQ which is a local
station Dolezal has legally changed her
name to nichette CD ah Wow in 2016
because she's a screwed up human being
is accused of first-degree theft by
welfare fraud perjury in the second
degree and false verification for public
assistance her potential punishment
under RCW seventy four point oh eight
point three three one could include up
to fifteen years in prison because
Dolezal changed her name will be
referring to her as Nikki Diallo
according to court documents Diallo
illegally received almost nine thousand
dollars in food assistance and illegally
received one hundred bucks in child care
assistance total restitution according
to documentation is nearly nine thousand
dollars allegedly stolen from August
2015 through November 2017 so what
exactly happened well the investigation
into D Allah's alleged theft started in
March 2017 when a DSHS office of fraud
ability investigator received
information that Diallo had written a
book that got published the investigator
said he'd heard zlo say she was getting
public assistance but also knew a
typical public publishing contract
included payments of ten to twenty
thousand dollars the investigator
conducted a review of diablos records
and found she'd been reporting her
income was usually less than five
hundred bucks a month in child support
payments at one point when asked as to
how she was paying her bills she
reported barely with help from friends
and gifts however between August 1 2015
in September 2017 she'd installed nearly
84,000 dollars into her account and
she'd not report this to the Department
of Social and Health Services so there's
that now I feel bad for h 'l Dolezal is
obviously a mentally ill person right
that's that's not hard to see Rachel
Dolezal is a mentally ill person she's a
white girl who believes that she's black
and she has lived a really dissolute
life
I mean her life has been just a mess why
is it that if I say that Rachel Dolezal
is mentally ill this is treated as
common knowledge but if I say that a man
who believes he's a woman is mentally
ill this is treated as crazy and let me
tell you something believing you're a
member of a different race is a lot less
biologically suspect than believing that
you are a member of a different sex okay
just putting that out there
by Rachel Dolezal doing what everybody
always knew she would write she it turns
out that she is a fraud
shocking no no who can believe it who
can believe it now in in other news in
just a second I want to get to a
shocking story out of parkland Florida
but first you're gonna have to go over
to Daley we're calm so over at Daily
wire calm for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription to daily wire and this
means that you get the rest of the show
live it gets you part of our mailbag you
get the rest of Michael Mills a show
live there are some Andrew Clavin alive
and when you get a subscription you also
get first access to our event tickets so
we have events coming up in Dallas in
Phoenix they're virtually sold out but
if you had bought a subscription you'd
have had first access to those tickets
especially those VIP tickets which would
have allowed you to meet me and we could
have hung out but we can't now because
you didn't spend a little bit of money
and get a subscription so get a
subscription gang it ain't hard at the
annual subscription for $99 a year and
this will allow you all of those great
benefits plus it's cheaper than the
monthly and you also get the leftist
here's hot or cold tumbler I could not
even bring it with me on this trip to
New York because to do so would have
threatened its integrity I'm you know
what I really want to get it scratched
up pers Noi been a treasured place in my
home and in my office I would never want
to do anything like that you
wanna listen later for free go over to
SoundCloud go over to iTunes go over to
YouTube Google place to train in those
places subscribe leave us a review we
always appreciate it we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so in other news over in parkland Texas
is an amazing story according to the
local 10.com several parents of victims
at Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School
massacre said that a former Broward
Sheriff's Office deputy Scott Peterson
who stood outside the old school for
several minutes while bullets rang out
had done his job their children might
not have lost their lives
I think Peterson is the lowest form of
life available said Fred Guttenberg
whose daughter Jaime was gunned down on
the 3rd floor my daughter would be alive
if not for him Broward County Sheriff
Scott Israel publicly criticized
Peterson for his inaction during the
shooting but now is amazing they report
that recently surfaced has some victims
families calling for a nude
investigation of Peterson for a case he
handled four years to the day prior to
the massacre the case involved two 17
year old students bullying a 14 year old
freshman with one holding down the
younger boy by his ankles while the
other kicked the victim grabbed his
genitals and then took the victims own
baseball bat and began shoving it
against his buttocks simulating rape
threw the boys clothes one of those
assailants the boy who allegedly held
down the victim was Scott Israel's son
the sheriff of Broward County Bret
defense attorney Alex Ariza
who represents shooting victim Anthony
Borges who shot five times in the
Valentine's Day Massacre but survived
said the case could have led to felony
charges he could have been charged with
a lewd and lascivious and I'm being
conservative said arias a--
peterson claimed in the report it was
simple battery under the board it's
discipline matrix and he decided to give
both of the boys attacks a three day
suspension what is that it's like an
alternative universe law Oryza said
because what happens because you're in
the school you don't have to obey
regular laws in fact the Disciplinary
matrix includes sexual misconduct and
serious battery both of which arguably
applied in this case arias a said quote
you will never see somebody grabbing
somebody's crotch and poking some kid in
the butt with a bat and getting a simple
battery for it
Gutenberg's had the facts of the
incident infuriated him and Scott
Peterson failed to do his job again it's
just another example of a bad crime and
somebody not being held accountable it's
kind of interesting the intersection of
the same people well it's more than
interesting obviously it means that
there was some sort of relationship
between Scott Israel the sheriff of
Broward County and deputy Peterson one
of the boys father says listen if deputy
Peterson had been made to answer for
this maybe he been it would have been
replaced by a more competent deputy but
this wouldn't have been the sheriff's
son what a sexual assault has been
reduced to a simple battery apparently
Peterson noted in his report the
victim's parents were notified of
discipline
and did not request additional law
enforcement action but who cares it's
the job of the police to enforce the law
it's not the job of the parents to
enforce the law just amazing just
amazing and Scott Israel remember has
been defended by a bunch of the people
in parklands who wish to put blame on
the NRA for what happened in parkland
the reality is this is a law-enforcement
screw-up in every possible way and
corruption in local law enforcement is
not relegated to issues of race very
often it is relegated also to issues it
includes issues of personal corruption
of relationships between people who then
use those relationships in order to
forward their own ambitions or to
protect people who they know what a
horrifying story and really just bad
okay meanwhile ESPN continues to lose
subscribers the reason I bring this up
is because I think so much of our sports
debate now whether it's the NFL kneeling
controversy which you know I don't know
why you would kneel for the flag I think
they're better ways to protest the
entire NFL kneeling controversy has been
driven by media coverage if players were
not getting media coverage for dealing
then they wouldn't be doing it and part
of that is the insane politicization
that has taken place over at ESPN now I
used to be a huge ESPN fan a huge ESPN
fan for a while I subscribe to ESPN The
Magazine I was a probably our daily
watcher I would get up at 6:00 when I
was a kid I would get up at 6 o'clock in
the morning because before the internet
was really great with clips I used to
get up at 6 o'clock in the morning every
morning and run into the den and turn on
ESPN and watch SportsCenter hoping to
catch my White Sox highlights and now
you can watch eight hours of ESPN
without ever getting a Sports highlight
instead ESPN has become entirely talk
radio combative back and forth between
liberals and leftists there's there's no
one on the right ever on ESPN ESPN is
completely to the left anybody who even
expresses a mildly conservative opinion
is immediately thrown out or suspended
and this happened multiple times well
there's a great article at The Wall
Street Journal about the politicization
at at ESPN here's they say John skipper
was furious one of his star anchors
Jamel Hill had sent a tweet calling
President Donald Trump a white
supremacist mr. Trump supporters called
for her to be fired prominent black
athletes defended the anchor who's
African American sitting in his office
last September mr. skipper then ESPN's
President lit into miss Hill according
to people familiar with the meeting if I
punish you he told her I'd open up to
protest and come off as racist if I do
nothing now fuel a narrative
among conservatives and a faction within
ESPN that the network had become too
liberal mr. skipper chose to spare miss
Hill mr. Trump weighed in on Twitter
ESPN is paying a really big price for
its politics and bad programming people
are dumping it in record numbers
the president's fruit was hyperbolic but
it's happed into a real anxiety at ESPN
what was the way forward for a company
shaken to its foundations by the cord
cutting revolution and the answer is
pretty obvious cover sports you idiots
but they haven't covered sports instead
they've decided to counter program these
discussion programs every half an hour
on the half hour for the entire day well
why would anybody subscribe to us PN for
that you can just listen to Bill Simmons
his podcast and get better sports
coverage and better support Siskiyou
listen to the ringer I listen to them
they're great you can you can listen to
all that there's tons of great sports
programming out there you can get on
demand why would you tune into sports
television on ESPN to watch a couple
people who don't know anything about
politics jabber about politics utterly
useless so according to The Wall Street
Journal executives at the sports media
giant wanted to seek out new audiences
by spicing up shows with opinionated
analysis and debate including on
SportsCenter it's struggling news and
highlights franchise except that the
struggle at SportsCenter has largely
been occasioned by the politics of
SportsCenter
again I can like I can watch 45 minutes
of SportsCenter without seeing a single
baseball highlight they've decided which
sports they want to cover and it's
usually enough on the NBA there's very
little coverage of the MLB I've done
full articles on this over a daily wire
about the discrepancy in coverage and
that's because they're going after
different demographics the reality is
that demographically speaking the
disproportionate share of people who
watch NBA NFL our NFL tends to be pretty
proportionate across the spectrum NBA
NBA fans tend to be disproportionately
African American and MLB fans tend to be
disproportionately white ESPN has
decided that because a lot of viewers of
the NBA watch more sports program it's
not stupid decision they'll focus more
on the NBA but in doing so in completely
cutting the MLB out and the hockey for
example I mean they've cut a lot of
their baseball coverage baseball tonight
is barely on anymore they've cut out a
lot of the audience they used to have
like Legacy subscribers executives the
sports so but the amount and intensity
of political expression generated sharp
internal disagreements over whether ESPN
was appropriately taking part in the
broader national conversation or whether
top executives were encouraging a
divisive company culture and giving too
much leeway to
to promote left-leaning views both on
air and in social media and this of
course is absolutely true Linda Cohen
who's one of the most prominent female
anchors in April 2017 she have a radio
interview and she said
ESPN's politics were pushing away
viewers and the network had overpaid for
NBA rights so skipper of course called
her to yell at her why ESPN found itself
torn up by the nation's partisan
politics traces back to its fundamental
business challenge its status as cable
TV's most expensive channel had become a
liability
consumers grew fed up with their monthly
cable prices big cable distributors
began offering discounted packages that
didn't include the network and consumers
started opting for these so there's
obviously a cost-cutting problem a cord
cutting problem rather but that doesn't
answer the real question which is was
the answer to that to completely
counter-program along the lines of stuff
that nobody wanted to see here's the
reality Sports is a politics free zone
for most people who watch it they're not
interested in the politics and more
politics you ladle into our sports
unless we're gonna watch you the NFL
realized it ESPN had better or they're
gonna go the way of the dodo bird okay
we will be back here tomorrow first
actually I have to do a couple of things
so first I want to do a couple of
Federalist Papers because we haven't had
a chance to actually do the Federalist
Papers in the recent past so I have to
catch up on a couple of them and then
we'll do some things I like and some
things that I hate so let's begin with
the Federalist paper so when do
Federalist paper 29 which we didn't do
last week and we'll do Federalist paper
30 for this week so Federalist paper 29
is by Alexander Hamilton and this is the
concluding Federalist paper about
whether there should be a standing army
in the United States that is run by the
federal government so Alexander Hamilton
says yes and then he says that if the
standing army starts to make trouble the
states will stand up to them so for all
the talk about you don't need militias
you don't need armed citizens Hamilton
repeatedly and throughout the Federalist
Papers claims the best insurance against
an overreaching federal government will
be states that are able to call upon
their citizens to defend themselves
against federal overreach critics
according to Hamilton said the federal
army would be chief law enforcement
mechanism and they said that there was
no provision for Posse Comitatus so
there are a lot of people who said well
instead of the federal government having
its own law enforcement body why don't
they just call on the states to help
them enforce the law now ironically
enough there's a push by the states
against Posse Comitatus after the Civil
War they said we're not going to be the
levers of the federal government but at
the time there are a lot of people
saying we don't need the federal
government to be quite so overreaching
we'll just have the state enforce
some of this law well Hamilton says that
Congress could create such mechanisms
but in reality a lot of these fears were
justified because as the federal
government grew there is a serious move
to to grow the federal law enforcement
bodies virtually every branch of the
Federal Executive now has some sort of
law enforcement agency attached to it
with guns and with them with bulletproof
vests and the whole deal and that's
because in the end the government is
essentially a group of people with guns
okay the government is a body that is
made for force as as knock would say and
so here's what Hamilton says is what
shadow of day here here is his guarantee
against federal tyrannies is what shadow
of danger can there be from men who are
daily mingling with the rest of their
countrymen and who participate with them
in the same feeling sentiments habits
and interests what reasonable cause of
apprehension can be inferred from a
power in the Union to prescribe
regulations for the militia and to
command its services when necessary
while the particular states are to have
the sole and exclusive appointment of
the officers if it were possible
seriously to indulge a jealousy of the
militia upon any conceivable
establishment under the federal
government the circumstance of the
officers being in the appointment of the
state audit wants to extinguish its the
idea was that there'd be these state
militia that we call that by the federal
government is supplementing as
supplementary forces there'd be this
core of experts at the federal
government level and they would be the
expert military and then the states
would supplement that with the National
Guard for example in reality obviously
the Army has grown way beyond these
bounds the military's one way beyond
these bounds for both good and for ill
in some cases so Alexander mostly for
good I think but in terms of threats to
to state rights that don't involve
actual horrible racism and Jim Crow and
slavery it's it's not great the federal
government has the capacity to override
everybody okay so time for Federalist
paper number 30 so Federalist 30 now
Hamilton shifts topics in Hamilton
instead of talking about the standing
military he's going to talk about why
the federal government should be able to
levy taxes directly so under the
Articles of Confederation which preceded
the formation of the Constitution of the
United States the federal government
requested money from the state
government so they would say we need
this much money from you Connecticut and
Connecticut would have to turn in the
money one problem Connecticut wouldn't
turn in the money so Alexander Hamilton
says listen we can't run a federal
government along these bases he says
national credit will be destroyed
if we can't levy taxes to support
issuance of bonds for example when we
are in the middle of a war he says money
is with proper with propriety considered
as the vital principle of the body
politic as that which sustains its life
in motion and enables it to performance
most essential functions a complete
power therefore to procure a regular and
adequate supply of it as far as the
resources of the community will permit
may it be regarded as an indispensable
ingredient in every Constitution from a
deficiency in this particular one of two
evils must ensue either the people must
be subjected to continual plunder as a
substitute for a more eligible motive
supplying the public wants order the
government must sink into fatal atrophy
so either the government's gonna come in
and steal your money on an occasional
basis or they're going to collapse oh
the federal government will collapse
does it seem to be doing under the
Articles of Confederation and then he
makes the argument that we need a system
that allows the federal government to
tax directly the citizens of the United
States now the income tax was not a
thing the income tax was not
constitutional until the sixteenth
amendment to the Constitution which
happened in the early 20th century up
until then most taxes were through the
form of property taxes on the state
level import taxes on the federal level
and the coming that come the the
government was able to run on that basis
the government was able to run on the
basis of that now I've advocated for
national sales tax I think Hamilton
probably would have advocated for the
same but that is not this just because I
think tariffs are generally bad policy
and using them as a way to garner
revenue seems like seems like a mistake
but here is here is what Hamilton says
if we don't have the power to tax then
we're gonna fall into a national debt
from which we'll never be able to
recover embedded in this message is a
simple message for us we now have 20
trillion dollars in national debt the
only reason anyone is buying our bonds
is because they expect us to pay that
off the only reason they expect that to
pay us to pay it off is at some point
they assume that we will massively tax
our own citizenry which means we better
get our debt under control or as
Hamilton says we're gonna have to tax
the living bejesus out of the entire
American public okay that is what's
happening next that's what's coming next
so just have that in mind Hamilton knew
it and so should everybody else okay
time for a couple of things that I like
and then we'll do a couple of things
that I hate so here is the thing I like
today
Van Jones has been talking about
bipartisanship with the Trump
administration Van Jones actually is
working with the Trump administration on
a number of issues including Van Jones a
communist okay man Jones is working with
them on criminal justice reform this
idea that no one in the Trump
administration is willing to reach out
to the other side of the aisle is
nonsense Trump is much more willing to
reach out to the other side of the aisle
than Barack Obama ever was and that is
perfectly obvious here's Van Jones
talking about it the first step act will
actually make their lives better they'll
let them earn their way honk home sooner
it will stop women prisoners from being
shackled and when they're having babies
there's a lot of horrific stuff that's
been going on that this bill will
eliminate and I just can't tell you the
entire Democratic leadership in the
house including Nancy Pelosi voted with
on this bill and for this bill that
Donald Trump engineered kuschner before
it was a bipartisan breakthrough
okay so Van Jones obviously making a
good point here and bottom line is that
this is true I mean the Obama the Obama
ministration never won't breach not
Republicans there's no effort to reach
out to Republicans Trump's at least
trying
he's just being refused it's one of the
reasons his approval ratings are going
up okay time for a quick thing that I
hate okay so dr. David Hansen who's
created the eerily lifelike Sophia robot
has now revealed his vision for a future
of androids in a new research paper so
here is what he says he says that humans
are already making love to sexy robots
in 2018 but soon they'll be able to
marry their amorous Androids as well so
androids will get the same civil rights
as humans by the Year 2045 which
includes the right to marry own land and
vote in general elections good luck good
luck with the voting in the general
elections although they can't do worse
than then most people are doing with
their votes so his new paper suggests
that people will be marrying robots
here's my problem with the whole
marrying of robots idea presumably these
robots will be unable to procreate right
you're not gonna have robot children and
they don't actually have you dry they
are not capable of making babies
it shows the tremendous selfishness that
is overtaking our vision of marriage
when people are talking about marrying
robots obviously because this is a
lifeless thing right this is a program
thing
now maybe AI develops to the point where
robots have lifelike intelligence but
they certainly don't have the ability to
procreate and the notion that you're
going to marry a piece of machine
because it pleases you this is not what
marriage was for as soon as you said
that marriage was between any two
individuals who loved each other as
opposed to an institution about the
bearing and rearing of children you're
immediately running down the path to
people marrying whatever it was that
they pleased also you do have to ask the
question whether you can actually get
proper consent from a sex robot you know
if we're gonna be in the area of consent
it seems to me that you know animals
can't give consent I guess the idea what
the the robot is the robot isn't the
lives who cares I mean you're just you
know presumably having sex with a chair
essentially but at a certain point there
will be serious moral issues with you
having sex within it with a with an
Android if the Android achieves a
certain level of intelligence and this
is something that people who are
participating in this sort of activity
ought to consider it's funny actually
Silicon Valley sort of dealt with some
of these issues actually in the last in
the last season in a very funny way but
what it really goes to is the human
beings have decided that all of the
universe is about fulfilling our
solipsistic desires this seems to me uh
turley untrue particularly in the realm
of marriage any successful marriage is
based on precisely the opposite notion
so maybe you will be pleased to marry a
robot but if so what you really have is
not a marriage it's you pleasing
yourself in every sense of the world in
in every sense of the word okay so we'll
be back here tomorrow with a lot more
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah alvera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018